these boxes contain an abrupt message
for Prime Minister Matteo Renzi and his
labor market reforms not this way the
slogan of Italy's largest labor grouping
the cgil union as it prepares to take to
the streets le diga economic we are
bitterly against this government's
economic policies especially the removal
of job guarantees it's dangerous and
further weakens Italian labor laws we're
already familiar with these employee
hostile policies from former right-wing
governments lovato job security is
something that many young Italians can
only dream of Georgia Angeles has had to
eek out his living for years with badly
paid jobs in call centers when you've
been dizzy and waving on the
twenty-fifth of every month I wait for
my job to be extended by a further month
I don't receive a phone call just a text
message if it doesn't come I know the
job is over no texts no job Louisiana
level though union activists are well
aware of the situation for them the job
security guarantee is untouchable they
don't agree that loosening it will help
resolve the economic crisis yep
aerovironment engineer ali reza del
governo NAL's the government's new
measures will not help create jobs
they've promised tax breaks for new job
openings but at the same time companies
are not able to sell their products at
home or abroad was easily needs his new
industrial policies non non possono
produ ray Prime Minister Matteo Renzi is
not impressed by the union's campaign he
wants to modernize the Italian economy
that means he's not ready to give in to
reform resistant unions no even seen the
cattle we would like to see a union that
defends jobs and not the union's own
status quo we want to create jobs we
don't want to have to listen to
professional bureaucrats
yeah despite resistance from his own
party Renzi has already forced
legislation through Parliament to partly
loosen job security guarantees as far as
the general strike goes many younger
Italians want no part of it those like
29 year old Giorgio do not feel that the
unions represent their interests but
they also feel neglected by the
politicians